Nos dicen que: "Una tolva para grano en forma
de cono", y resaltan tolva en azul aquí en
el ejercicio -en caso de que quiera saber su
definición, es algo que almacena grano y éste
puede salir por abajo- "tiene un radio de 10 m en
la parte superior y 8 m de altura". Dibujemos eso,
tiene forma de cono y tiene un radio en la parte
superior, así que la parte superior debe ser la
base, supongo que podríamos pensar que debe
ser la parte más ancha del cono. Entonces se
ve como algo así, eso es lo que nos dicen en
esta primera oración: tiene un radio de 10 m,
por lo que esta distancia justo aquí es 10
m, y la altura es de 8 m, dicen que tiene 8
m de altura. Luego nos dicen que "Está lleno de
grano a 2 m de la parte de arriba". Una forma de
pensar en esto es que está lleno de grano hasta
esta altura, así que esta distancia será 8 - 2,
esto va a tener 6 m de altura. Eso es lo que nos
dice esta segunda oración. "La tolva verterá el
grano en cajas con dimensiones de 0.5 m por 0.5
m por 0.4 m. La tolva vierte el grano a un ritmo
de 8 m³ por minuto". Tenemos mucha información
aquí. La primera pregunta es ¿cuál es el volumen
del grano en la tolva? Antes de pasar a estas
preguntas, veamos si podemos responder esta, de
modo que será el volumen que tenemos justo aquí,
en la parte roja, el cono formado por el grano.
Pausa este video y trata de resolverlo. Bueno,
de videos anteriores sabemos que el volumen de un
cono es igual a 1/3 • b • h. Ahora, sabemos que la
altura es de 6 m, pero lo que necesitamos hacer es
calcular el área de la base; bueno, ¿cómo hacemos
eso? Tendríamos que calcular el radio de la base,
llamémosle r justo aquí, y ¿cómo lo resolvemos?
Bueno, podemos ver estos dos triángulos y darnos
cuenta de que son triángulos semejantes: esta
línea es paralela a esta línea, este es un ángulo
recto y este es un ángulo recto porque los cortes
de estas superficies van a ser paralelas al suelo,
luego este ángulo es congruente con este
ángulo porque podríamos ver esta recta como una
transversal entre rectas paralelas, y estos son
ángulos correspondientes, y luego ambos triángulos
comparten este ángulo, de modo que tenemos ángulo,
ángulo, ángulo. Estos son triángulos semejantes,
así que podemos establecer una proporción aquí,
podemos decir: la razón entre r y 10 m, la razón
r / 10 = a la razón de 6 / 8; y luego podríamos
tratar de resolver r: r es igual a, multiplicamos
ambos lados por 10 y obtenemos 60 / 8, 60 / 8,
8 cabe en 60 siete veces y nos sobran 4, entonces es
igual a 7 4/8, o es igual a 7.5. Y si queremos
calcular el área de la base que tenemos aquí,
si queremos calcular esta b, esto es igual a πr²,
de modo que b en este caso va a ser π multiplicado
por 7.5 m², y el volumen, para responder a
la primera pregunta, va a ser 1/3 por el área
de la base, esta área que tenemos aquí arriba
que es π (7.5 m)² multiplicado por la altura,
multiplicado por 6 metros. Y veamos, podríamos
simplificar esto un poco: 6 / 3 o 6 x 1/3 = 2.
Déjenme usar mi calculadora. Nos dicen: "redondear
a la décima de metro cúbico más cercana",
así que tenemos 7.5 al cuadrado por 2 por π es
igual a, bueno, si redondeamos a la décima más
cercana, serán 353.4 m³, entonces el volumen es
aproximadamente 353.4 m³. Esta es la respuesta
a la primera parte. Y luego dicen: "¿Cuántas
cajas completas se llenarán de grano?" Bueno,
hablan de las cajas justo aquí, la tolva verterá
el grano en cajas con dimensiones de 0.5 m por 0.5
m por 0.4 m. Podemos imaginar estas cajas que se
ven así: 0.5 m por 0.5 m por 0.4 m, de modo que el
volumen de cada caja va a ser el producto de estos
tres números, el volumen de cada caja va a ser
igual al ancho por la profundidad por la altura,
entonces (0.5 m) (0.5 m) (0.4 m), y deberíamos
poder hacer esto en nuestra cabeza porque 5 por
5 es 25 y 25 por 4 es igual a 100. Pero luego
tenemos que pensar en uno, dos, tres dígitos
a la derecha del punto decimal, entonces uno,
dos, tres, esto es igual a una décima: 0.100
m³, una décima de metro cúbico; así que ¿cuántas
décimas de metros cúbicos podemos llenar con esta
cantidad de grano? Bueno, sólo será este número
dividido entre una décima parte, dividir entre
una décima es lo mismo que multiplicar por diez,
y si multiplicamos esto por diez vamos a obtener
3,534 cajas. Una vez más para entenderlo mejor:
cada metro cúbico puede llenar diez de estas
cajas y esta es la cantidad de metros cúbicos
que tenemos, así que si multiplicamos esto por
10 obtendremos la cantidad de cajas llenas. Y
una forma de pensarlo -lo hemos visto en otros
videos- es que cambiamos el punto decimal una
posición a la derecha para obtener esa cantidad
de cajas, y es importante darse cuenta de que son
cajas completas, porque cuando obtuvimos 353.4
redondeamos hacia abajo, así que tenemos esa
cantidad, pero no vamos a llenar otra caja con
cualquiera que sea este error de redondeo que
redondeamos hacia abajo. Entonces, la última
pregunta es: "al minuto más cercano, ¿cuánto
tiempo toma llenar las cajas?" Bueno, este es el
volumen total y vamos a llenar 8 m³ por minuto,
así que la respuesta aquí será nuestro volumen
total que es de 353.4 m³, y lo vamos a dividir
entre 8 m³ por minuto, y eso es igual a 353.4 / 8
= 44, si queremos redondear al minuto más cercano,
44 minutos, toma aproximadamente 44 minutos
llenar todas las cajas. Y hemos terminado.